Simplify 2a squared
over 3b to the fifth,
all of that to the fourth power.
So here we can use the property
that if I have x over y,
and I'm raising that
to the nth power,
this is the same thing as
x to the nth power over y
to the nth power.
And we could see that
with an example real fast.
If I had, let's say I had x
over y to the third power,
what would this be equal to?
This would be x over y
times x over y times x
over y, which is going
to be equal to x times x
times x over y times y times y.
And this is clearly x to the
third over y to the third.
So I just gave you a particular
example of why this works.
Hopefully, it gives
you enough confidence
or makes you feel good
about using this property.
So let's use it right here
in our actual problem.
So we have 2a squared
over 3b to the fifth,
all of that to the fourth power.
So this is going to be
the same thing as 2a
squared to the fourth power.
So let me write it this way.
It's going to be 2a squared
to the fourth power.
Let me do the fourth
power in blue.
All of that over 3b to the
fifth to the fourth power.
And now we can use
the property that if I
take the product of
things and raise that
to a power, that's the
same thing as raising each
of the things in the
product to the power
and then taking their product.
So this is going to
be the same thing.
Let me just write
the property here.
So if I have x times
y to the nth power,
this is the same thing
as x to the nth times
y to the nth power.
And you could do
a similar argument
that we did right here to
see why this works out.
So let's do that over here.
2a squared to the fourth power
is going to be equal to 2
to the fourth power--
I'll color code
it-- 2 to the fourth power times
a squared to the fourth power.
And then all of that over 3b to
the fifth to the fourth power.
That's going to be 3 to
the fourth power times b
to the fifth to
the fourth power.
Now, the last interesting
thing here-- and we
can evaluate what these
numbers come out to be.
2 to the fourth power-- let
me just do it right now.
2 to the fourth--
2 squared is 4.
2 to the third power is 8.
2 to the fourth power is 16.
So this right here is 16.
3 to the first power is 3.
3 squared is 9.
3 to the third power is 27.
3 to the fourth power is 81.
So this over here
is-- let me do it
in that green
color-- this is 81.
And to simplify
these terms here,
we just have to remember the--I
guess we call it the power
property or the power
rule of exponents.
And that's just the notion
that if I have x to the n
and then I raise that
to the mth power,
this is the exact same thing
as x to the n times m power.
So if we wanted
to simplify this,
our numerator is now 16--
that's the 2 to the fourth--
and then a squared and
then that the fourth power.
That's going to be a
to the 2 times 4 power,
or a to the eighth power.
This is literally 2
times 4, so we're just
multiplying 2 times 4.
This 2 times this
4 to get that 8.
And then in the denominator,
we have our 81 and then
b to the fifth and then
that the fourth power.
That's going to be b to
the 5 times 4 power or b
to the 20th power.
So I got 20 by
multiplying 5 times 4.
And we're done.
This is about as
simplified as we can get.